first of all how was mother's day we had
a first mother's day
it was the best so i was totally spoiled
emotionally
and materially if that's a word
um it was amazing it's now a word
mother's day was really special for me
because it was birdie's birthday
too which i kind of feel like oh it just
makes like it reminds you of all the
labor and the hard work you went through
so it was a special day i got to share
with you and we have two first birthdays
coming up right how will we celebrate i
know
so we're gonna do it together we're
gonna do it together we're thinking wild
one's theme
and um we're just gonna go full out in
our own way
in a good way for a one-year-old
one-year-old
yes well how awesome is it to be here
tonight to be celebrated at the mtv
movie and tv awards
i mean mtv movie and tv awards are
iconic
and so to be a part of it now and to
also like honor unscripted
is just so amazing because we work
really hard too even though we're not
scripted
you know we like to be honored and win
awards
right i mean we put everything out there
by the way how does it feel to get
dressed up on a red carpet tonight mamas
you look amazing
thank you it feels yeah it feels really
good we popped champagne
over it we got really excited just the
hair the makeup we got our nails done
yes who are we wearing show this off for
a minute oh yes
so maria lucia and we want it to be can
i blame the pandemic on that
so we're actually wearing the same brand
so maria lucia which we're really
excited about we kind of went with this
like mermaid theme we feel like
we wanted to be like a little like hip
trendy and i see you guys on instagram
getting your fitness
in like are we feeling sexy are we
feeling good we are we're actually like
you know the pandemic i think everyone
kind of had their coveted
gain and you and i had our pregnancy
major pregnancy gain so getting stuck in
arizona during the summer was not good
for my thighs or anywhere else
um but it's been just feeling good
taking ourselves to a whole other level
physically i just realized i needed it
like if we're not in the ring doing it i
need to do it in a gym
or in your garage break my garage oh
gotta let you guys go thank you so much